[Music]
hey everybody what's going on it's bobby
and we're back in the geek culture
studios because we're talking about
cabinets a lot of you in the comments of
the last few videos been asking what are
about these cabinets what kind of
cabinets are they where'd you guys get
them so we're going to talk about that
today these are a brand new cabinet
system from terra vault in singapore and
they're touting it as the world's first
smart display cabinets we're here to
talk about them with that being said
this video is brought to you by secret
lab now here at geek culture we really
like our secret lab chairs as a matter
of fact we use them primarily for all
the work we do and they come in a
variety of different sizes omega titan
titan xl and talk about fabrics and
materials you've got pu 2.0 leather you
got genuine leather and also soft weave
and in terms of collaboration we got
world of warcraft dota lol dc characters
harley quinn joker batman even game of
thrones there is a secret lab chair for
you for more information click on the
link in the description below
first off they come
well there's two cabinets here each of
them are separate units and we put them
together and the size is 100 by 40 by
200 centimeters
so they don't come any taller they don't
come any shorter there's three variants
there's the sentinel 2 the sentinel 8
and the sentinel 10 and that's depending
on the lighting sources that are inside
now you will get
aluminum
shelf on the middle areas but you can
opt to have aluminum shelves on all of
these if you want to do that for extra
weight these come with glass shelves uh
there are doors that open up
as you can see here
two on the top and bottom and
they close up relatively well
and there you have it very secure very
nice now in our videos we actually open
up these panels because of the
reflection coming from the light source
so that's why you don't see it in my
home studio actually have the doors
completely off and i just showcase all
my items on there because it does
reflect light but if you're in your home
and you're not worried about filming
there no issues at all with it and the
great thing about these is is that they
call the smart display cabinet because
there's rgb lighting all throughout this
so depending on the option that you get
you can get one large light panel on the
top of each stack
and you can also get led strips on the
shelf case in point on this one here let
me just pull this out
these are led strips that you can remove
and plug in there and they're all
customizable depending on the color that
you want so for each stack here this can
be blue this could be red they could be
all one color you can configure it
because it's smart this is a wireless
system that you can configure with your
phone and so we do have that done here
at geek culture so depending on the
video that we're doing or depending on
our mood for the day we can completely
customize this to our liking but usually
for filming we tend to go more for
lighter colors just because it kind of
showcases all these great items inside
of the cabinet case in point we've got
the lamborghini sean from lego we've got
the infinity gauntlets from lego here
yes these are lit up and there is a usb
hub that is in back of this that is
plugged into this cabinet system that
allows you to plug in these items so you
can have them constantly lit up and it
just adds another element to it now the
cool thing about this is actually how it
plugs in let's come over here zacky for
a moment we're coming to the side here
come over here real quick so you can see
this these panels right here are
actually where you plug things in case
in point these lights here you just turn
it take it out
and you just pop it in and turn it on
and the power sources and there's a
current that's going through this track
that automatically powers these lights
so this also works for the usb hub as
well so that's really some of the
ingenuity going on in this cabinet
system uh that allows you to really
customize it so here at geekolo should
we like to showcase a lot of these toys
so we have this light here for the lego
uh the nasa space shuttle and of course
we've got baby yoda over here we want to
highlight a little bit
and we have these lights throughout the
system here which is really really cool
but here in singapore where the
company's from they'll install them for
you if you like to do that but if you're
in america or another country they will
ship it over to you and it comes in a
flat pack system so that allows you to
sort of configure it yourself now
there's pros and cons to this because
i'll talk about that in just a bit with
the cable management system but it will
leave you to sort of i mean there's an
instruction manual to walk you through
it but it's up to your own discretion
how you want to
wire everything how you want to hide the
cables or not hide them it's totally up
to you so let's actually get down to
that right now now the cabling system
that comes with this is white color the
cabinets are black as of now now i've
heard from terabot that they will be
coming out with a white shelf in the
near future and if they do so the cable
management system will look beautiful
with that we're asking for black cables
they haven't come out with them yet it's
only white but actually zac if you come
up close we'll kind of show you what
it's all about so this is actually a
power source
um
as plugged in you can see the cables are
all here and we're wrapped up in here
with velcro straps and a little bit of
3m tape to keep it all hidden and then
we actually tuck the cables on the back
of this track here as well now
for some people they might want a more
cleaner setup and unfortunately that
will be up to your engineering and your
expertise in that field
teraball is allowing you to sort of
customize this to your own liking
we did find it to be a little bit
challenging when we were first setting
up these cabinets because of course we
don't want cables hidden because we have
a black cabinet and the cables are white
so we try to do our best to hide them
and uh we had some help from the terabot
team they were able to sort of rig this
up here so you know to the average
person they're not going to see it
unless you really look inside and go oh
i see how it's designed
but maybe that's something they can
improve on in the future or maybe you
can do it at your own you know show
discretion however you set it up in your
own home but the overall design of this
cabinet system is very robust it is very
solid it's designed for statues for
heavy collectibles i use camera
equipment on mine that i put on my
camera lenses and everything for display
purposes but you can put a lot of
different things on this and also these
shelves are configurable so you don't
have to have it stacked like this you
can actually remove this all let's say
you're doing bear bricks thousand
percent bear bricks you want to put bear
bricks here you can do that on each of
these shelves now of course it does come
with the levelers inside the package
when you get it so
because you will have these pins here
that you will have to balance out the
level to make sure that your shelf is
angular so there's no let's say
predetermined holes here where you can
actually just you know mark it and slide
the shelf in or lock it in no it's going
to require a little bit of patience in
terms of setting it up but as you can
see the end result is beautiful we have
led strips here here here and of course
we have the spotlights there
and the same on the way down now there
are different configurations that you
can get for this and you can get more
led strips if you like you can remove
the doors there's a lot of options from
teravault in terms of however you want
to customize this
but the end result is your toys your
collectibles are going to be well lit
you can change the colors
the evenness of the light is actually
really important to me i like this
especially with these led strips here
that are hidden under uh by the shelves
so it gives it a nice glow it's not
overbearing and of course you can dim it
if you'd like to you can customize it
however you want it to be because these
are smart lights and they're completely
customizable within the smart app on the
apple or android device so now i've got
the smartphone here i'm going to show
you how the app works and how you can
control the lights through the app okay
so i'll turn it to
blue
then i'll turn it to red
then i'll turn it to yellow now i have
all four grouped this way
what if i want to separate that well i
can actually
go top left
and i'll make this
red i'll go bottom left i'll make that
blue
and then
top right
let's say i make that white
and then on bottom right
i'll make that
yellow and then if we want to do disco
time
terrible baby yeah
[Music]
we got various different presets here
we've got read night working leisure
colorful dazzling
music
soft
that more and more you know dimmed down
look working bright white
leisure less brightness nighttime
very dim we're all about the color here
then of course you can kind of edit this
as much as you want to do that and
customize this as well and yeah it's it
has its little kinks as little issues
setting it up but i think once you have
it dialed in
i think
it's really cool and i love the the
aspect that you can really have the
different lighting effects to it so
this is uh
this is a fun cabinet and i mean at my
home i don't have the collection that
geek culture does unfortunately i'm
working towards that so i have more
camera equipment and have some
mandalorian stuff and gonna get some
things in the near future but now
there's some things i do want to point
out for this case in point this the
depth of this now um it's about 40 cm
thereabouts now i collect hot toys so i
have the dark knight tumbler and the 89
batmobile which are very wide and very
long you know items unfortunately
they won't fit in here unless uh the 89
will not fit for sure because it's too
long the tumbler i'd have to tilt on an
angle and i'd have to move one of the
shelves up because of the size of it so
this is something i did mention the
terawald about this and they said that
they are looking in the future to sort
of make deeper cabinets for those
collectors out there that have larger
items that they want to display but as
of this stands right now the standard
size for these cabinets are 100 by 40 by
200 centimeters uh so do take that in
mind if you have any large collectibles
that you want to display you might have
to put them on top as you can see right
here we don't have a lot of room so yeah
but on my in my home i actually have my
lego set up so i have my lamborghini
sean on top the ferrari and the bugatti
i just need to get the lighting kit like
they have here to sort of illuminate
that and make it look pretty badass
which i'm looking to do because as you
can see
this lighting kit on the cn makes it
look so much better when it's inside
from the engine to the tail lights to
the headlights to the interior that's
badass and it's the cool thing is it's
all powered by this usb hub that's in
the back of this from teravault you can
actually get more of those if you want
to do that so for a lot of toy cabinets
we want to keep it you know brighter
white light so you can show all the the
colors and your toys and collectibles
and statues as the artist or you know
the the company design them to be but
maybe
you just want to turn everything
off you can do this all within the app
now i'm not controlling the app mind you
right actually we have young here who's
controlling the app on his smartphone
because it's it's paired to his phone
another cool feature to the terabolt
system of course is the smart plug
system this allows you to connect it to
google assistant or alexa case in point
hey google turn off geek display
okay
like that hey google turn on geek
display
pretty cool right so that's essentially
the teravault cabinets um they're cool
they're nice
but
in terms of wiring be patient
and if you need any help
ask us in the comments section below or
message terrible they will help you out
with that because it can be a little bit
challenging anyway guys
those are cabinets let us know your
thoughts in the comments section below
any questions you have as i mentioned
ask us we'll try to answer them for you
with that stay safe take care and we'll
see you in the next one bye
[Music]